now you probably thought you'd Seen the
Last of him but Tony fauci is back
Georgetown University Medical School
just announced he's starting next week
as a distinguished professor
I think what I have to offer is
experience and inspiration for the
younger generation of students if I
accomplish that I think I'll make a
major contribution to Georgetown
now I want to remind everyone what kind
of expertise fauci has he's an expert at
posing for magazine covers he's an
expert on himself as you can see from
the many Fouche related items in his
office he's also an expert on being
wrong and getting paid top dollar for
doing it it's as simple as black and
white you vaccinated you're safe you're
unvaccinated you're at risk simple as
that
let's triple mask joining me now Dr J
balacharya from Stanford University
School of Medicine Professor I have not
seen you in the studio I've been sitting
here for two years since our epic Town
Hall great to see you so much fun um all
right what's your reaction to this well
the problem is that uh if you look at
what he's actually done during the
pandemic Laura he's lied to the American
public over and over and over again
first on you know first mass don't work
but no no I was lying to you I just
wanted to spare the mess then he said uh
60 for herd immunity 70 for her immunity
then oh no I was lying to you because
you couldn't handle the number and then
he said if you get vaccinated you can't
get the disease you can't pass it on
over and over again he has basically
tried to disassemble in order to
manipulate the behavior American people
how is he going to look in the face of
students and say you have to tell people
the truth in public health well what
about the professors the doctors the
researchers who were either threatened
or lost everything since some cases
they're licenses to practice medicine
all because of this edict that was
basically pushed out into all of
Academia into research institutions you
defy fauci you're out yeah I mean I
faced it personally Laura right so I
because I spoke up with the Great
Barrington declaration saying lockdowns
are a bad idea he and Francis Collins
essentially organized a devastating
takedown of you know of me it
essentially sends a signal that people
like him who decide who gets funding who
gets status can destroy you if you cross
them and the exchange of free ideas in
medicine how much was that compromise
during this pandemic given what we know
about the origins of this virus I mean
we know that that for a fact people
censor themselves for a long time Laura
what people would would do is they'd
they say okay well if I speak up I'm
going to cross him and I'm gonna you
know my career might be threatened a lot
of scientists would write to me and tell
me thank you for speaking up Jay I can't
speak up because I'm gonna I face all
these these you know I stand to lose all
the stuff he manipulated that situation
with the letter was in the article in
nature about how the virus couldn't have
really started in a lab or very unlikely
that it started in a lab yeah that's the
proximal Origins paper yeah if you look
at the foyed emails from January 2020 he
spent all his time or a very large
fraction of his time worried about
people were going to think that might
have started in a lab how about the
boosters we're supposed to all get the
boosters and we find out most of the
people getting sick have gotten multiple
boosters really sick now yeah well he
was a essentially a pharmaceutical
company salesman but probably the best
one they ever had well we know that
Pfizer has given an enormous amount to
Georgetown University over the years big
Pharma has given huge amounts to
research organizations that in and of
itself can be problematic can it not be
yeah I mean there are there are
definitely conflicts of interest
inherent in both the position he held
which I think he abused his power and
the position he's going to I'm just well
actually I'm just thinking about the
students right so what example
Georgetown setting by taking somebody
who has been so ethically compromised
and putting him in a university you know
as University Professor that's their
highest position
um I mean I think you know it's one
thing to have them as a guest lecturer
but you have to put them in context like
hit for this but no one's going to put
them in context that's the problem the
media never held them accountable a
couple of us did
no one did I mean the Lord I don't think
history is going to remember him very
well I think the the failure of this
pandemic
that which we're going to just remember
him mainly for that well I hope history
actually records this correctly you and
I know what the truth is uh and our
viewers do certainly Dr badachari thank
you so much great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else